not done one of these for a little while
I just want to talk about some books and
this video is sponsored by curiosity
stream and nebula there is a whole bonus
video associated with this one over on
nebula stick around to the end to find
out what that's about
if people didn't see it last week I made
a video about the history of global
warming and after the amount of effort
and energy that went into that this week
I'm just going to do something nice and
chill nice and easy gonna talk about
some books that I've been enjoying and
you might enjoy too and maybe you want
to give some as Christmas presents I
will leave links to all the books I talk
about down there in the description
those are affiliate links so if you buy
something from them then I get a small
Kickback from it doesn't cost you
anything but it helps me out so I have
done one of these videos for a while
because I published a book earlier this
year called firmament and it turns out
that when you are writing a book and
getting it over the finish line and
getting it published and seeing the
reviews come in and doing the sort of
promotion for it I wanted nothing to do
with books the other books at that time
at least for me I was totally booked out
and so there was a period of like six
eight months maybe well I just didn't
have like an active book that I was
reading which is the longest time that
I've had that as an adult and I needed
that time off I think my brain was just
saturated with books but I am very glad
that I have come back to reading because
over the past couple of months I've
found some really really good and
interesting books that you might like
too first of all Dominion by Tom Holland
you're gonna have to make do with this
digital art because I lent my copy to a
friend as soon as I finished it which is
a very good sign Dominion is a book
about the history of Christianity and
how it has impacted the west and the
author makes the claim that it has a
unique influence and does a lot of
things that a lot of other religions
don't in terms of its cultural impact
and this is a subject that I am
fascinated by and this is a book that
I've kind of been looking for for quite
a while and it hits the Mark it's very
good well researched well written
recommendation I will say that it is a
meaty book it's nearly 600 pages long
it's quite dense and while it is very
enjoyable to read it's dense is probably
the word you do have to go back and look
up some names because obviously there
are so many people in this history and
I've found at least that I had to remind
myself of some of the key players from
time to time so it's not a light frothy
book that you can read very easily like
by the side of a pool although I did
read a fair bit of this book on my
honeymoon I'll also say that the book
makes a lot of claims about how unique
Christianity is amongst the major
religions in terms of its cultural
impact and while the arguments within
the book make sense and are
self-contained I think it's interesting
what it doesn't mention and how it
doesn't talk about any other religions
and how they did things as well so it's
a slight shortcoming but considering the
breadth of the topic I can understand
why he didn't want to make it like a
thousand pages long Now for Something
Completely Different the color of Magic
by Terry Pratchett this may surprise
some of you but this is actually the
first pratchet book I've ever read there
were plenty of kids who I knew when I
was in school who read Pratchett and
swore by it and this is going to sound
slightly strange I'm really enjoyed the
book but I'm really glad I didn't read
it when I was a teenager Terry Pratchett
is a very funny very clever writer what
I will say is that his style has a
certain level of
snark going through it that I
immediately identified in the people who
I knew at school who read this stuff I
was like ah that explains it that's why
you turned out that way I really really
enjoyed this again I'm not putting the
book down at all I thought it was great
it's an easy recommendation I think for
a lot of people with the caveat that I'm
glad I didn't read it when I was younger
because I think it would have impacted
my personality in a way but I wouldn't
like I don't know if that really makes
any sense I don't know if anyone in the
comments wants to back me up here but
like I think this is a book that is best
enjoyed by adults who've already kind of
found their own voice in the world to
give you a skinny on it this is the
first entry in the Discworld series it
introduces this idea of a fantasy world
that is a disc with water flowing off of
the edges and you're following a few
different characters notably the wizard
wizard wince rind the wizard rinse wind
the characters in this and the setting
and I mean literally everything like it
is all incredibly creative really
enjoyable and as I've already said very
funny I know there's an immediate sequel
following the events to this book called
Over The Edge which I'm definitely going
to be reading and I just know I'm going
to be falling into the Discworld novels
so yeah easy recommendation with that
caveat of maybe this is something for
kind of people in your 20s and 30s I
would hesitate to recommend this to like
a 12 year old Simon read Douglas Adams
instead completely shifting gears again
our biggest experiment by Alice Bell was
another book that I devoured this year
that name may be familiar to some of you
who watched the video last week that's
because this book formed the foundation
of the script of that video this is a
sweeping history of the climate crisis
and the surrounding social and economic
context of it so this isn't just a story
of people like arenius and calendar and
Keeling it's also how electricity came
about you know who discovered it how did
we Electrify various systems why was
natural gas used for some systems but
not electricity why did we end up using
coal all those kinds of questions as
such this is the climate crisis plus
it's all the surrounding material and
it's very comprehensive in what it's
trying to do which is a plus point I
think I'm all for a social and
historical and scientific context but I
think it also counts as a negative in
this case while all the context is
incredibly important to understand the
climate crisis I think that when you are
trying to tell the story of the climate
crisis having too much of that material
whilst it is necessary in this case at
least has kind of muddied the waters and
it's obscured the the story for lack of
a better word of of the climate crisis
if you're someone who is much more
interested in the social background of
you know how electrification came to
happen and how the oil empires in
America came to be and who financed them
then this is definitely a read that I
would recommend if you are after a book
that is just about the discovery of
global warming and the history of the
theory then I would much rather
recommend the discovery of global
warming by Spencer R weird both of these
were actually the the key sources for
last week's video script and another
book that was key to researching the
video it was firmament my book and I'm
mentioning this because it is coming out
in North America next week I think it's
actually already available as an audio
book which I narrated sorry but it's
available in physical format in North
America next week and the reviews that
were coming from not North America have
been incredibly positive I'm slightly
Blown Away by the response to the book
like I've heard from some people that
they're recommending it to their
students in college which is
nuts I will say that it would make a
good Christmas present for anyone who is
interested in the climate crisis and how
we know what we know about the
atmosphere not just weather prediction
or the climate but the whole physical
system that's that's what I wanted to do
with this book it's also an introductory
book it's not a textbook it was written
with high school students and college
students in mind so people who may be
interested in going into atmospheric
science
that was what I was trying to accomplish
at least and I think according to the
reviews I've managed it so yeah linked
to fundament along with all the other
books down in the description in last
week's video I mentioned that if there
was interest I would do a part two about
the events of the 70s 80s and 90s and
people are interested so I can confirm
that's gonna happen it'll be sometime in
the New Year like in a couple of months
time like maybe February give me a
chance to write a script and make the
video but when that video does come it's
going to be largely inspired by losing
Earth by Nathaniel Rich this was a book
that I devoured I started reading it and
over the course of like an hour I
realized that I was going to finish this
in a day it's written like a thriller
it's really impressive as the title
suggests and with the context I've given
you this is about the 70s and 80s and
90s and how we went from the science
being very well understood about the
theory of global warming even if we
didn't have a huge amount of data and
not really much happening about that
until kind of really the 2000s and 2010s
the most heartbreaking part about this
book is that it makes it very clear that
there was a very real possibility we
could have taken action in the 90s or
maybe even sooner you know the right
people were in the right positions in
the American government specifically and
knew about the science
but they were stymied at every turn and
it's ugh
yeah it's a tough read sometimes very
easy to read there's not a huge amount
of Science in here this is very much
about people and politics not about the
science of the climate crisis highly
recommend this to pretty much anyone to
be honest along with merchants of Doubt
by oreskis and Conway I've mentioned
this book before but taken together with
this these two provide a very good
account of why we didn't do anything
about the science however if you prefer
your grimdart future to be fictional I'm
just going to make a very quick mention
of Armageddon by Aaron devsky Bowden
this is a book published by the black
Library it's about Warhammer 40 000 and
fun fact this was actually a copy that I
bought for myself as a present when I
was in Stockholm visiting some friends
I'll be a card up here you can watch the
Vlog about that trip and this is one of
the most famous books by the black
library and it's kind of clear why
because there's character progression
the black Library publishes a lot of
books I'm just gonna be honest a lot of
them aren't great but they're not
classic literature Armageddon is
definitely a step above most of what the
black Library publishes I think Aaron
denske bodens a pretty solid author and
you actually get some progression in
terms of characters and and larger
themes going on in the SEC setting which
is much more ambitious than most authors
try to do so full credit I enjoyed it I
will say that it's not a masterpiece
like some people hype it up to be if you
are interested in the story of this but
you don't want to read the book there is
actually a fan made film on YouTube by a
guy called Richard Boylan which is
amazing I actually think it's better
than the book it adds in a couple of
things and takes a few things out that
just enhances the overall story so I'll
leave a link to that in the description
as well uh it's a very visually striking
fan project very very cool probably
watch that instead of reading the book
and then lastly my most recent read the
hollow Crown by Dan Jones I actually
finished this this week this was
excellent It's an account of the wars of
the roses and the period of time before
and after that Conflict for those of you
not familiar the wars of the Roses was a
conflict in 15th century England between
the houses of Lancaster and York that
resulted in the death of King Richard
III and the Ascension to the throne of
Henry VII he became the first of the
Tudor monarchs it's actually the
inspiration for Game of Thrones we're
taught in school that there was a bunch
of conflicts between riches the third
and Henry VII Battle of Boswell field
happens in 1485 and the tutors win they
go on to become this huge dynastic
family and they seal the deal with a
marriage between the two families what
this book makes it clear is that the
history is much much more interesting
and way more complicated than that this
book starts with Henry V and I pretty
much picks up straight after the Battle
of Agincourt and uh takes you right the
way through the Tudor dynasty and how
the Tudors kind of put their mark on
history and how they were really really
good at propaganda and creating that
story that I just told you this is a
work of narrative history so it's like
it's telling you the story you know it's
it's not dramatizing it like having
lines for the king or the queen or
whatever it's just telling you what
happened in the manner of a really
really good Storyteller Dan Jones
very very impressive I'm going to be
reading his back catalog after this if
you like history if you like Game of
Thrones I don't think I can recommend
this more highly I thought this what was
just amazing I devoured this in not very
long at all and that brings us up to the
present on my to read pile I have a huge
number of books including some that I'm
going to be reading for a future project
but also a bunch that have been sat on
my to read par for way too long I think
these are probably the three that I'm
going to be reading next over Christmas
in particular I'm looking forward to the
Anarchy based on the success of the
hollow Crown apparently I'm a sucker for
punishment and just huge books and I've
also heard good things about this by
William mccaskill but I'll be honest am
I going to read these books before I
don't know something that I just see on
the Shelf in waterstones and impulsively
buy and immediately read
probably not so that's my recent reading
and my near future reading you may
notice there's a whole heap more books
behind me there's more that you can't
see down there and there's actually way
more downstairs and I thought that you
might be interested in a bookshelf tour
so I've made that video over on nebula
in that nebula exclusive I talked
through the bookshelves and the stuff
that's on them books and a couple of
other things and make some
recommendations based on the much larger
collection that have not featured in
videos yet you can get access to this
bookshelf tour at the link in the
description anyone can watch one video a
month on nebula but if like over half a
million users you would like full access
to a huge library of exclusive content
from Top educational YouTubers the
ability to download videos to watch when
offline and a viewing experience that
involves no adverts not even in the
videos themselves like this then you can
sign up at curiositystream.com Simon
Clark signing up at that link also gets
you access to curiositystream which if
you don't know is the best source of
documentaries on the internet instead of
watching the same Show on Netflix over
and over again maybe you could learn
about ancient cities rendered in 3D with
megopolis or the Artemis Mission or
about any number of subjects across the
sciences and Humanities they've got
stuff for adults and kids perfect for
rounding out your entertainment options
to get access to both curiosity stream
and nebula for an entire year costs only
14.79 so just over a dollar a month for
a more enjoyable version of YouTube and
a comprehensive library of options to
make your evening viewing smarter that's
curiositystream.com Simon Clark with
thanks to curiosity stream and nebula
for sponsoring this video thank you so
much for watching the video I hope that
you took some recommendations from this
again all the links are available down
there in the description some of these
will make great presents I'd be happy to
receive them if I hadn't already read
them remember that Furman is out in
North America next week and if you'd
like to watch that bookshelf tour then
you know where to find it here's some
recommended viewing from me next if you
haven't already you can subscribe to the
channel down here and that just leads me
to say thank you very much again for
watching I hope you enjoyed and I'll see
you in the next one